NEWSPAPER IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
STARTS WRITING CRAP LIKE THAT.
WELL, PRESIDENT TRUMP TRAVELED
TO INDIA LAST WEEK TO MEET WITH
THAT COUNTRY’S PRIME MINISTER.
PRIME MINISTER MODI.
ONE OF THE CENTRAL ISSUES AT
THEIR MEETING WAS THE H 1 V VISA
PROGRAM.
IT DOLLS OUT ROUGHLY 85,000 VISZ
SASS A YEAR TO MOVE TO THIS
COUNTRY AND TAKE AMERICAN’S
JOBS.
THAT’S WHAT IT DOES.
VAST MAJORITY GIVEN TO PEOPLE
FROM INDIA.
AS A CANDIDATE IN 2016, DONALD
TRUMP CALLED FOR ENDING THIS
PROGRAM ENTIRELY BUT AS
PRESIDENT THAT HASN’T HAPPENED
THOUGH THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAS MADE THE VISA SLIGHTLY
HARDER TO GET.
SO WHY IS THE PROGRAM STILL
AROUND?
WHY IS IT SO DURABLE?
THAT’S AN EASY QUESTION TO
ANSWER.
IT’S A FAVORITE OF TECH
COMPANIES WHICH CLAIM THEY
SIMPLY CAN’T FIND ANY AMERICAN
SKILLED ENOUGH OR SMART ENOUGH
TO DO TECH WORK.
THAT’S A LIE.
A PROVABLE LIE.
COMPANIES ROUTINELY USE H 1
VISAS AS A MEANS TO FIRE
EXISTING AMERICAN WORKERS AND
REPLACE THEM WITH LOWER PAID
FOREIGNERS.
OFTEN THE FIRED WORKERS ARE MADE
TO TRAIN THEIR REPLACEMENTS
BEFORE THEY ARE TERMINATED.
THE PROCESS FOR THE REPLACED
WORKERS IS PAINFUL AND
HUMILIATING.
COMPANY EXECUTIVES TELL THEM
THEY ARE ASSIGNED TO A
COMPLETELY NEW COMPANY TO TRAIN
FOR THE ROLE THEY ONCE DID.
WHERE THEY ARE NOT NEEDED
ANYMORE, THEY ARE CAST ASIDE.
WE RECENTLY SPOKE TO SOME AT&T
EMPLOYEES WHO WERE, QUOTE,
REBADGED BY THE COMPANY TO TRAIN
CHEAPER REPLACEMENTS FROM INDIA.
HERE IS THEIR STORY.
[PHONE RINGING]
>> YOU KNOW THEM, YOU FEEL
HELPLESS AND YOU JUST ACCEPT IT.
>> Tucker: THIS FORMER AT&T
EMPLOYEE SPENT NEARLY TWO
DECADES AT THE COMPANY.
A FEW MONTHS AGO AT&T INFORMED
HER THAT SHE WAS NO LONGER
NEEDED.
>> I’M AWARE OF AT LEAST 8,000.
>> 8,000 WORKERS?
>> AT LEAST 8,000.
IT COULD BE MORE.
>> Tucker: SHE IS ONE OF MANY
FORMER AT&T WORKERS WHO FOUND
OUT ON CORPORATE CONFERENCE
CALLS THAT SHE WAS GETTING WHAT
THEY CALLED REBADGED TO A NEW
COMPANY WHERE SHE IS FORCED TO
TRAIN A LOW COST FOREIGN
REPLACEMENT.
>> TODAY IT’S MY JOB.
TOMORROW IT COULD BE YOURS.
>> Tucker: SHE EXPECTS TO BE
OFFICIALLY FIRED WITHIN A YEAR.
>> WHAT CAN YOU DO?
>> WHO CAN YOU CALL?
WHO DO YOU TALK TO?
>> Tucker: MANY HAVE TURNED TO
SARAH BLACKWELL AN EMPLOYMENT
LAWYER WHO REPRESENTS AMERICAN
WORKERS.
>> WHAT AT&T IS DOING IS THEY
ARE FIRING THEM AND HAVING THEM
WORK FOR THE COMPANY SO THEY ARE
WORKING FOR AMDOX ACCENT SURE
AND TECH THAT HUNDRED DR. AND
TRAINING THEIR REPLACEMENTS
THERE.
>> Tucker: ONE FORMER EMPLOYEE
TRAINING HIS REPLACEMENT TOLD US
THE NEW WORKERS ARE ALL FROM ONE
PLACE.
>> THEY ARE ALL FROM INDIA.
MOST OF THEM FROM FROM -- SOME
ARE FROM MUMBAI.
>> Tucker: OUR PRODUCERS
OBTAINED SHOCKING DOCUMENTS FROM
THE TRAINING COURSES.
AT&T AND ACCENTURE.
WARN THAT INDIAN MEN WILL NOT
SHAKE HANDS WITH AMERICAN WOMEN.
>> WE ARE AN AMERICAN COMPANY
AND WE ARE LITERALLY GIVING AWAY
OUR LEGACY.
WE ARE GIVING AWAY OUR KNOWLEDGE
BASE.
WE CAN’T GET THOSE THINGS BACK
ONCE WE OUTSOURCE ALL OF THIS.
>> Tucker: AT&T BOASTS ABOUT ITS
CORPORATE WOKENESS OUTSIDE ITS
CORPORATE CAMPUS IN DALLAS.
BUT THE COMPANY GAVE ITS SOON TO
BE FORMER EMPLOYEES A LIST OF
APPROVED TOPICS FOR DISCUSSION
WITH INDIAN REPLACEMENTS AND
URGES THEM NOT TO DISCUSS
INDIA’S HUMAN RIGHTS RECORD OR
RELIGIOUS CONFLICT IN INDIA WITH
THEIR FUTURE REPLACEMENTS.
>> THEIR GOAL IS TO OFFSHORE AS
MUCH AS THEY CAN TO LOW-COST
COUNTRIES.
>> Tucker: MANY COMPANIES SAY
THAT THE FOREIGN WORK VISA
PROGRAM HELPS U.S. COMPANIES
DEAL WITH THE WORKER SHORTAGE.
>> YOU WOULD NOT SEE FIRING
WORKERS IF YOU REALLY HAD A
SHORTAGE.
>> Tucker: MANY TECH COMPANIES
SAY THAT THE HSB HIRES ARE
SMARTER THAN AMERICANS AND
BETTER WORKERS, TOO.
ONE FORMER WORKER WASN’T
CONVINCED.
>> SOME OF THE FOLKS IS THAT WE
WORK ARE VERY SHARP.
WE HAVE SOME THAT THEY WERE
DUMBER, WE WOULD HAVE TO WATER
THEM TWICE A WEEK.
>> Tucker: AT&T FOR ITS PART
ISN’T GOING BROKE.
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
COMPANY’S PRIORITIES, IT’S
SPENDING $100 MILLION ON AN
EXTENSIVE RENOVATION OF ITS
HEADQUARTERS.
AT&T’S CEO RANDAL STEVENSON
MAKES NEARLY $30 MILLION A YEAR.
THAT’S NEARLY 366 TIMES THE
AVERAGE AT&T WORKER.
THE OUTSOURCING HELPS TO PAY FOR
ALL OF THAT.
>> THEY SAID YOU DO NOT GET A
SEVERANCE PACKAGE.
YOU ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR ONE
SINCE WE FOUND YOU ANOTHER JOB.
THAT’S WHAT WE WERE TOLD.
WE WERE ALSO TOLD THAT WE WOULD
NOT GET OUR ANNUAL BONUS NEXT
YEAR UNLESS WE AGREED TO GO WORK
FOR ASSENTURE.
>> WHEN YOU ARE WATCHING SO MANY
PEOPLE PEOPLE SUFFER AT THE
HANDS OF A FEW GETTING RICH AND
NO ONE IS PROTECTING THEM, THEN
PEOPLE WILL STOP THINKING
CAPITALISM IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO RUN THE COMPANY CARE ABOUT
THE WORKERS?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: A SPOKESMAN FOR AT&T
DENIED THAT ANY OF THIS IS
HAPPENING AND ASSURED US THAT
ANYONE WHO HAS BEEN REBADGED CAN
RETURN TO AT&T AT ANY TIME.
>> THEY SAY MANY OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES HAVE ALREADY BEEN
PLACED IN NEW AT&T JOBS.
>> WOW.
WHERE ARE THEY?
>> IT HASN’T HAPPENED TO YOU?
>> IT HASN’T HAPPENED TO ANYONE,
I DON’T THINK.
I THINK THAT’S A BLATANT LIE.
[BUSY SIGNAL]
>> Tucker: IT’S INFURIATING AND
DEEPLY UNSETTLING BY OUR